there's been some weird stuff going on i
hear people like there's too many
conspiracy theories
you know i hear trump is going to give a
presentation and then he cancels it and
the state department thing pops up do
you guys see this no yeah with the state
department
claimed that trump's term had ended
today
or whatever or was going to end today
and mike pence's as well
and now they're saying it's like a rogue
employee i guess let's just we'll just
we had this one planned for later but
let's just we'll jump straight to this
one check this out from buzzfeed
a disgruntled employee changed the state
department's website to say
that trump's term ends today sources say
secretary of state mike pompeo is
launching an investigation after
biographical pages for the president and
vice president were changed monday
i don't i don't buy the story everybody
started sharing the state.gov
biography of trump that it said donald
trump's term ended and then
the current date plus like a couple of
hours it seemed like
some kind of basic script to just say
you know donald trump's term ended and
then
display time you know what i mean so
that no matter what happened every time
someone went to it it would show them
the current time based on like utc time
zone or something that's what it seemed
like
so i don't know exactly what happened
but this thing was a rogue employee
perhaps
buzzfeed says a disgruntled employee at
the state department changed the
biography biographies of president trump
and vice president mike pence
to say their term was coming to an end
on monday
nine days before the president-elect joe
biden is to be sworn in
two current serving diplomats with
knowledge of the situation told buzzfeed
news
the changes of the state department's
website come days after trump incited a
deadly insurrection okay we get it
buzzfeed
the president's biography was changed to
read donald j trump's term ended on
2020 2021 011 1949.
the vice president said 1944-22 the time
stamp on trump's page changed multiple
times
before both pages were removed around 3
50 p.m and replaced with a 404
reading we're sorry this site is
currently experiencing technical
difficulties please try again in a few
moments
one of the diplomats said that secretary
of state mike pompeo has ordered an
internal investigation into the matter
beginning with interns and employees
leaving the state department this week
and next ahead of the transition
to the biden administration so this is
what it looked like right here it says
donald j trump trump trump's uh donald j
trump's term ended
and the date and then you can see for
pence it was very very similar
you know my responses when i saw this
right to jail
believe it or not straight to jail
whoever did this needs to get locked up
no joke
charges because we're at a time we're
extremely vulnerable
okay this country is going through
serious turmoil nancy pelosi
i'm i'm not here to play games i know
that what i'm about to say is
is a strong statement but nancy pelosi
according to pen
the joint chiefs of pentagon officials
asked them to stage a military coup
and we can argue she didn't know what
she was asking for and that's fine
but it needs to be said pelosi went to
the pentagon to the joint chiefs and
said
do not obey lawful orders from trump in
certain circumstances incompetence is
not a defense
if she didn't know she was doing she was
still doing it and and and the argument
i give is she's been in congress for 50
000 years i mean of course of course she
she would know
she was in like dinosaur congress yeah
so she went to the pentagon and said
if trump gives you orders to like start
a war or fire nukes or whatever
disobey them and they said that would
amount to a military coup they cannot
remove the president from the chain of
the
chain of command he is the
commander-in-chief
why isn't that being said more of so
anyway look the point is
considering this state we are in with
these kind of things happening
now would be the worst possible time for
hackers to break in
to mess with our country to start a war
or to come at us
and then some dumb intern or whatever
was like make a joke about troop
resigning
and now you get people panicking how
many what if people like
you've got people on edge we had just
people we just had people storm the us
capital
this is not the time for jokes so that's
why i don't know if i believe it
because a lot of people were worried
this was a hack some kind of hack that
went in and they added this or whatever
but either way
could you imagine what would happen if
people around the country saw that
message
we no longer have a president no
statement no knowledge i remember when
twitter got hacked
the associated press got hacked by the
syrian electronic army to put out a
tweet from
from the ap saying that obama has been
injured and we lost like four billion
dollars in stock value
as soon as it happened and then as soon
as they corrected it it shot back up
but uh but uh only a 90 recovery
these kinds of things aren't jokes
whoever did this should get
the book and the bookshelf thrown at him
but they're
they're probably an obama holdover
and uh and in how many more days is joe
biden
they're probably gonna get the medal of
freedom yeah i mean that's you know i
mean i
i no i i agree i mean they they should
be i don't think they should go to jail
i think they should just
be fired no you should just be you don't
look and i i i don't know what happened
like did anybody go into like uh
the wayback machine and see what this
thing looks like because was that
was that time was that time stamp there
and all they did was just add some htl
html saying that his term is over like
right now
so at a certain point in the web in the
archives
there's nothing it wasn't there someone
placed it there it seems like around the
end of december
to have like the current date or
something okay for whatever reason we
don't know why the date was changing but
there are versions from from december
whoever did this
in my opinion was broke into these
systems
is you no one was granted authorization
to claim trump was removed from office
or resigned
that's that's serious that's that's not
shutting down his twitter account
that's telling everyone in this country
the president's gone well it's only
telling people
that they're going to that website i i i
do i think they should.gov
do i think they should be punished yes
but but what's but what's the
the state of the crime the state
department website yeah but what's the
crime
well the the actual statutory crime is
the violation of the computer fraud and
abuse act unauthorized access to a
computer server
for which i think the minimum is like 25
years considering it was the state
department
that's serious i'm not okay with these
people playing games right now man
we just had five we have five people die
right okay we've got people
freaking out in this country we've got
dramatic escalation in in in every
political
uh arena censorship is going through the
roof
calls for the expulsion of republicans
for some dumb employee
make a joke but here's not but my my
point is
does anybody believe it no believe that
it was a rogue employee no
no does anybody believe that that oh my
god i just saw this timestamp but oh
that means the pres
yes yes nobody's believing because
trump is still in office no so where's
trump been he's not given a public
statement
and you know what i was hearing because
look listen i follow
as much as i can from all of these
different tribes i follow the mainstream
media leftists and the democrats and
republicans
and i listen to what the lefty you know
conspiracy people and the right wing are
there are left-wing people i saw posting
on facebook
saying trump was supposed to give a
speech
and then this website pops up announcing
he's resigned and now his speech was
canceled
they believed it they did
look man regular people that look
imagine that little old lady in the
capital you saw that picture of the
granny waving a little flag
that lady has no idea what's going on
i'm not trying to be mean but come on
she was confused and bewildered
like joe biden and she sees on the
website trump is no longer president
she's gonna
believe that and and look it's not even
about whether or not people believe it
for the most part it's about the fact
that somebody
because they were an angry trump
derangement syndrome [ __ ]
broke into a system exposing a
vulnerability in our in our
state department like dude we're on
we're on edge so much we can't we can't
we can't do this man well i'm not saying
that
i'm look i'm trying to be objective here
i'm this person should be punished yes
do i think that that the people that had
nothing to do with the murder
be charged with felony murder no so
again i'm trying to
you know i'm trying to i'm not saying
lower the temperature
i agree i'm not saying give them 25
years but i'm saying they should
be given you know some kind of charge
it's got to be you can't go into
government systems and do this and
that's fine
you know i don't think that they should
go to jail for 25 years though that's
right
right ridiculous no no no right i agree
joe biden will pardon
him anyway did you imagine joe biden
being like this patriot
who tried to remove donald trump to
build back better
we're going to pardon him first thing
i don't should be arrested i don't know
who it is if it was one person
i mean you could pull some out and be
like this is the guy that did it and we
don't know if that's right either so
i'm going to say that this person who
did it probably
put it out there to say you know it's
like hey look there's this
thing look at look at this it's crazy
right you know
if you know i saw a tweet i think it was
from redhead libertarian i'm not
entirely sure so if i'm miscrediting you
but it was like that point when you
realize our systems are made of are
cobbled together with sticks and stones
that was
me oh that was you yeah as you tweeted i
said that our systems are pretty much
held together with toothpicks and
cobwebs
like also wooden cotton candy because
there's nothing one person can do this
it's insanity
i didn't know you were the redhead
libertarian apparently i am but
think about what they've exposed with
this stupid joke
that some dumb rogue employee at the
state department
could break the whole thing think about
what that means
i wonder what else up there is fake
right now but it's everything i mean
look look at all these holdovers from
the previous
eight years all the leaks where do you
think those leaks came from
trump not republicans you know it was
funny i i think uh
i i'm gonna miss credit whoever said
this so i'm not gonna i'm not gonna
credit anybody it was me
the one thing trump was famous for he
didn't do fire people
yeah he should have just fired people
and he didn't do it
no he no he did he you know he he fired
he didn't fire uh the right people he
hired and fired
well okay that's true yeah uh but but
you know
you can't it's it's very hard to fire
government employees we know this
right trump it's one thing that to fire
to hire and fire
jim mattis it's another thing to fire
some low level
you know look look at what andrew struck
you know i mean peter peter struck sorry
andrew struck andrew mccabe you and him
yes thank you
uh i had a long train ride guys come on
yeah
but you know even it was it was hard to
get rid of them
too i mean there was push back there
right of course so
and and actually did something uh which
i'm not saying that this state
department guy didn't do something
i just i just think you know this
person's anti-trump
sure you know going off half the
government right you go off of the
previous discussion we had you know
we're talking about arresting people for
murder or whatever i wouldn't be
surprised if prosecutors are like
we're gonna bury them in books like it's
gonna it's gonna be an example tenfold
and then with this they're like well it
was just a harmless
prank we all hate trump right because
the orange man is bad so sure
that sounds okay yeah i don't i don't
see um
i don't can can we go back to the
inauguration for a second um
you know i think secret service probably
has everything covered as far as
safety and you know the these things
happen you know once every four years
like clockwork
so i think they kind of have everything
that they need to do and but honestly
i do not understand why this
inauguration
is even taking place i mean fine yes
the ceremony of you know him being sworn
in that has to happen but
having uh sixteen hundred people
in stands in front of the capitol isn't
that a super spreader
plexiglass between all of them and
they're gonna stay yeah get away from
them
so so what i heard is that he's going to
put his hand on the sanitizer instead of
the box
this is serious that in order to do it
what's going to happen is
once you arrive for the inauguration if
you're one of the attendees you wait in
line
they have you six feet apart and then
they have these
uh eight foot by uh three three by three
by eight
cubes like or not cubes like you know
big big chambers they lock you and make
a plexiglass and they both they padlock
it
and they put you on a forklift and just
carry you in and put you down you can't
leave you're trapped inside and you're
banging and it's airtight and there's no
sound
but then joe biden's safe so great
you get this look you're like no it's
like you got everyone's gonna die
because you had me halfway
no look i think i think it's so
hypocritical
for him to be holding this thing and
there's also going to be
onlookers too and vibration just like
his win
when they're on election night the guys
celebrate the guy's been wanting to be
president since the 80s
so this is his moment right nothing is
not even coveted
is going to stop this dude's moment and
you know what and
i'm not going to remember it and you
know what and you know what we're going
to hear in the evening i guarantee it
biden's inauguration was bigger than
trump's inauguration
crowd no no no no no i'm sorry i'm sorry
what they're going to do is
they're going to say that based on
online numbers they're going to make the
streaming for this makes it the biggest
inauguration in history
even though when trump was getting
inaugurated they discounted the live
stream views
and said that it was smaller than
obama's right and then trump was like
but look at the live stream you know
the webinars were huge well the way that
well i mean look i
i've been i've been a big critic of sean
spicer and the way he came
out and and presented it was just the
dumbest
way possible just just set the tone for
the entire four years by coming out
first thing i'm just like yelling at all
the reporters i want to sing a line
from alanis morris that's ironic about
the old man
but i don't want to say it because it
has to do with the president but i think
you understand the joke you know an old
man turned any eight he won he won the
presidency
oh yeah but i'll leave it i'll leave it
at that uh for those that
hit the song i guess you know just yeah
i'm really curious how they're going to
be doing the inauguration because again
we see
joe biden as the kind of plexi glass
social distancing always wear a mask 100
days of masks are coming presidency
how are they going to do it with
everyone standing together behind them
uh how are they gonna do it with that i
think i mean if they do it he's a he's
a gigantic hypocrite and he needs to be
called out but they will not because i'm
out on it and and that's what that's
what kills me
this double standard well this is one
thing already one thing already they
have a crap crap-ton of national guard
they have a crap town of troops
coming together mingling together and
again this is
also something that that has affected
small businesses
tremendously on such a severe level so
for them to pull this off it's really
going to be something and second of all
it's also interesting to see new york
governor andrew cuomo tweet
today that we need to open up businesses
so maybe
when the biden administration comes in
maybe there's going to be another kind
of flip of policies where kovit is going
to be magically over
like trump said well we've always been
saying that yeah and
and it's and it's been a joke but well
but but then joe biden keeps saying it's
going to be
long dark winter and you know what about
the inauguration
like biden comes out and he's got his
arm around like two young dudes wearing
hawaiian shirts and sunglasses
and he's kind of slumped over and he's
wearing sunglasses and a hat and they
like bring him up and like
his arms flopping and he flops onto the
bible i think there was a movie about it
yeah
yeah
well there was there was also a great
political ad for it too did you know
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah it was great
yeah it was awesome
to try and win and like it's great yeah
it's good fun
uh i hope it goes off like normal man i
i you know whatever it is
if there if they're hypocrites i would
be surprised it should be canceled well
they are hypocrites no it should legit
be
it should be the first zoom inauguration
and that's it
and and instead they're gonna have 16
the the stand holds 600 people
they're all going to be wearing masks
outside and you're like well
why could you do it there but you
couldn't do it in other
things like why were why were they
considered super spreaders and this
isn't well right and then with the crowd
and with because
you think you think the people are are
going to go yeah i'm just going to stay
at home like no
people are going to come out and i think
partially because they want to say
we need to make this bigger than trust
yeah they're going to yeah they're going
to take out their champagne bottles
they're going to be swinging it passing
around to the next person
and they are hypocrites so i think you
might be right because again we have to
understand here especially on the topic
of small business
the same people who are arguing that you
need to shut down small business to
defeat kovid
are the ones who are screaming right now
that businesses could do whatever they
want
they could censor whoever they want
because they're big private corporate
entities that should be left alone
magically again a major shift in policy
that no one's calling out or
or addressing thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast irl podcast
we do the show live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you